another crypto company just declared
bankruptcy this time it's Celsius which
if you're thinking sounds like deja vu
I'm sorry you're not in a Denzel
Washington movie this is unfortunately
the actual cursed timeline where for
some reason the summer Trend isn't socks
and Crocs it's billion dollar crypto
companies going bust in the worst
Financial recession of the decade now
some of you guys might remember just
days ago I reported on Voyager declaring
chapter 11 bankruptcy and today the
story is that Celsius said I'll have
what he's having but with a Twist
instead of a chapter 11 bankruptcy which
sounds bad celsi has filed for chapter
11 protection and financial
restructuring which just means that
they're bankrupt it means the same thing
it's kind of like when I was in high
school working fast food I told people
I'm not a fry cook I'm a thermal food
engineer but it didn't change the fact
that I was serving fries you know now
that I think about it me in high school
and Celsius the billion dollar company
have more uncommon than I thought we
both are broke and don't want to admit
it boom roasted and the point that I'm
trying to make is that Celsius is doing
the same thing that Voyager did in fact
they're doing it down to the T they
actually hired the exact same lawyer
that Voyager did according to their
filings that's right susberg is back and
honestly he's kind of becoming my mortal
enemy at this point it's like his bat
signal is whenever people lose money and
his superpower is arguing that they
never owned it in the first place I mean
this is honestly what these companies
are doing what these lawyers are arguing
that the customers never owned the
crypto that they bought in the first
place they were just lending it out for
some reason and I would love to talk you
through chapter 11 bankruptcy and why
Celsius does not qualify because they
clearly sold Securities according to
State Regulators but that's not really
the point of this video as I said we've
done that before and I don't want to do
it again instead I want to focus on the
uniqueness of this case and the unique
ways that Celsius has screwed over
investors so with that in mind let's
talk about hoddle you might have heard
this term before actually crypto Bros
say it a lot and it means hold on for
dear life it's a way of encouraging
people not to sell their crypto at a
loss and it turns out Celsius loved this
and they leaned into it they had
something called huddle mode in their
app basically it was a way for investors
to put a child lock on their accounts
basically freeze it for at least 24
hours and Celsius pushed this a lot to
customers not just early on but after
they suspended withdrawals too that's
right after they froze people's assets
they asked people to freeze their own
assets according to reports they were
pushing engage aging huddle mode as a
sign of support for Celsius during these
dark times now to be clear this is a bit
like asking a guy you just put in jail
to voluntarily handcuff themselves to
the bed right afterwards I mean nobody's
getting out anyways but celsius's
argument was hey we can unfreeze
withdrawals if you guys just all freeze
your accounts voluntarily I mean this
really was their logic we can't go
bankrupt if you guys never withdraw your
money and maybe this is just a testament
to how desperate their Community was
that a lot of people even bought into
this although some sought for what it
was but the ironic thing is despite
pushing huddle mode all the time you
know someone who didn't actually
practice what they preached Alex
machinski the CEO of Celsius that's
right guys and a move that no one saw
coming the c-suite turned out to be
Hypocrites it turns out that according
to a report by Arkham intelligence which
yes is a Batman reference but is no less
a made-up name than coffeezilla so I'm
not gonna make fun of it at least it's
not susberg or something but anyway
Arkham intelligence released a report
about Alex machinski and they showed
that he had a pattern of pumping and
dumping Celsius tokens while telling
people publicly that he was huddling
them in fact Alex tweeted about this in
October of 2021 lots to celebrate here
in London busy week with lots of deals
and events it pays to huddle now it
turns out that same day Alex sold 69 000
worth of crypto whoops two months later
more of the same quote all Celsius
Network Founders have made purchases of
cell and are not sellers of the token
now mysteriously this non-seller of the
token Alex this hodler managed to sell
16 million dollars worth of Celsius all
while telling his fans that he wasn't
selling but maybe even worse than Alex
profiting from what may have been a
profitable company was the Revelation
that Celsius may never have been
profitable at all turns out according to
Insider leaks they were actually really
bad at making any money at all which
gives more Credence to the Ponzi scheme
claim that we've been hearing a lot and
I know sometimes you guys accuse me of
being the one to say Ponzi scheme this
Ponzi scheme that and crypto which you
know
recently I have been saying a little bit
because there's been a lot of Ponzi
schemes but this time it's not me saying
it okay this is the head of defy staking
at Celsius that just accused Celsius of
being a Ponzi scheme he just got
revealed his name is Jason Stone and the
reason he revealed his identity is
because he just sued Celsius like I said
in his court filings he calls them
directly a Ponzi scheme and guys this is
the head of defy snaking there's no one
bigger than this guy who could like give
a more Insider take than the head of
defy staking he's the guy saying hey
they're not actually making the money
now look I'm not going to say Jason
Stone is some altruistic guy here in the
lawsuit he's clearly looking to be paid
not to mention it does appear that he
got some like nfts from Celsius in the
form of like a paycheck so his judgment
must be questioned on that account alone
but his story does kind of makes sense
which is basically the argument that
Celsius was not profitable which is
something we've heard time and time
again and it's the argument that even
when they knew they weren't profitable
they continued to Market High rates of
return as a way of getting more
investments into their system to pay out
the First Investors and then they told
these new investors to lock up their
money in the Celsius system with this
huddle mode all the while the founder
sold off for Millions so for all of
those Reasons I'm out and the lesson of
the story today is that well sometimes
it doesn't pay to hoddle